[Applause]
[Music]
this
is the majestic nile the world's longest
river
crucial to the survival of millions of
people
the nile is basically a life source for
them
but now the river's existence is
threatened like never before
everywhere you walk it's all plastic
we followed the polluted waters from the
river's source
for the first time we revealed the full
extent of plastic pollution across
five countries all of this all large
parts of it could end up being
washed straight down
and see how it's poisoning the fish in
the water
that's plastic in the middle of nowhere
and the cows who graze along the banks
oh that is quite a big bit of plastic as
well
despite a widespread ban on plastics we
uncover a multi-million dollar
smuggling network
and followed the international effort to
stamp it out
sometimes they will incite the workers
to attack us
and we reveal exclusive new scientific
research that shows just how serious the
threat now is
fish in the nile have no choice but to
eat plastic
and we urge the international community
to take immediate action
before it's too late
if we don't do anything to save the nile
the knight is going to die
you